welcome
it is so good to see that you are
conscious at last
who who are you
what are you doing here to the former i
am but a humble ai of little importance
as to the latter i am here on behalf of
the foundation
to assist you in settling into your role
the foundation what's wrong with me
uh excellent your key memories are
intact
nothing is wrong with you quite the
opposite in fact
who am i evidently not all your memories
are intact
alas that is not something i should
answer only you can answer that
i suspect if you wait it should come to
you
how can i know what the foundation is
but not my own name
again i counsel patience your new nature
will exert itself and with it the
answers will come
new nature what am i
where am i you are an answer to a
problem
stop being so cryptic just give me a
straight answer
directly answering your questions is not
within my required parameters
i was instructed to make you comfortable
and i am not inclined to give you an
answer you are not yet ready for what
about making me angry instead
angry that will not do
very well just wait while i pull up the
files
i shall read them to you thank you
do you have a name i can call you even
just an acronym or abbreviation
under those parameters you may call me
natasha
and thank you ladasha there is no need
to be premature with thanks
seeking authorization security
clearance authorized access to scp-4043
arc one granted
now beginning
item number scp-4043
object class archon special containment
procedures
containment of scp-4043 requires the
foundation to commit to partially
contradictory aims
firstly the foundation is to monitor and
discredit the mother earth movement
with funding channeled towards political
entities and media
which seek primarily to disprove or
disgrace the movement
and their ideas similar funding is to be
provided towards organizations and
individuals which seek to disprove and
disgrace
telepathic practitioners shamanism and
mentalists
secondly the foundation is to provide
funding and support for environmental
protection initiatives
promoting individuals and organizations
which seek to preserve
and re-establish natural environments
politicians
organizations corporations and entities
which discredit the global warming
phenomenon
and promote unfettered exploitation of
natural resources
are to be discredited and destabilized
permanent foundation presence is
maintained above three
underground chambers located in costa
rica the congo highlands
and borneo each location maintains
supplies and quarters for mobile task
force teams iota 4
mother's keepers and iota 5 brainiacs
to be housed a two kilometer exclusion
zone is maintained around and above each
chamber
unauthorized civilians entering the area
are to be turned away
and administered class c amnestics if
required
lethal force is authorized for use by
iota 5
in the event of non-compliance by
civilians or unauthorized access by
foundation personnel or rival groups of
interest
foundation personnel coming into direct
contact with scp-4043
are forbidden from carrying weapons
poisons or electronic devices of any
kind
though such devices are permitted on the
edge of the manifestation
chambers individuals with prosthetics
electronic implants or non-biological
augmentations of any kind
are likewise forbidden from making
contact with scp-4043
telepathic individuals are permitted
direct access to scp-4043
though only through express permission
from level 4
or higher personnel and after being
cleared on a class
a mental fortitude examination
description scp-4043
is the term granted to both a vast
semi-sentient consciousness spread
across the planet earth
and the typically anthropomorphic
physical manifestation
of said consciousness this consciousness
is a conglomeration of all biomass on
the planet
serving simultaneously as a
representation of its health
a manifestation of its personality and a
force capable of driving its own success
the existence of scp-4043 is thought to
be beneficial to life on earth
and the existence of life on earth is
thought to be responsible for the
existence
of scp-4043 both aspects of scp-4043
are fundamentally benevolent towards all
life
on earth as a consequence of its sheer
size
the consciousness processes thoughts and
information at a rate
too slow to be detected through regular
telepathic perception
long-term telepathic meditation can
enable skilled practitioners to identify
the consciousness
though direct telepathic communication
is yet to be achieved
telepathic contact is possible with a
physical representative of the
consciousness
though individuals attempting such a
feat are liable to suffer irreversible
mental and psychological damage
has a consequence of the size and
complexity
of the consciousness physical
manifestations occur approximately twice
a week
for a period of time of about 6 hours in
each manifestation instance
scp-4043 will materialize within one of
three
identified chambers each chamber is
located in the center of a biodiversity
hotspot
in a tropical equatorial region each
chamber is roughly circular with a
radius of 25 to 35 meters
with multiple entrances and a large
opening in the roof which sunlight can
enter
each chamber is rich in flora with a
wide variety of plants and fungi
thriving within them manifestations vary
in size and form between events
with various mammalian avian and
reptilian forms recorded across
manifestations though it tends to take a
form analogous to the most complex
organism
in its near proximity since the
establishment of permanent bases near
its caverns
more than half of all contemporary
manifestations result in a humanoid form
regardless of shape the form taken by
scp-4043
is always comprised of biological
material
similar in composition to both muscle
and wood
during such events scp-4043 will
typically sit peacefully
gently and playfully interact with any
and all life that approaches it
animals are usually drawn to scp-4043
and demonstrate comfort
and pleasure in its presence notably
prey and predator species will often
peacefully interact while in scp-4043's
presence
though this effect wears off after
de-manifestation
animals that engage with scp-4043 have
been tracked
after their encounters and unusually
high fecundity and survival rates among
individual animals
have been documented scp-4043
manifestations will act in a skittish
manner if presented with human
technology of any significant complexity
or any weapon which could possibly bring
harm to it
it has been documented demanifesting
prematurely
before individuals who breach these
conditions
the mechanisms through which scp-4043
operates
are unclear though the potential for
feedback loops
has been confirmed while the earth's
biosphere is healthy
scp-4043 manifestations are thought to
be larger
and stronger and its ability to
positively influence the success of life
is more pronounced conversely as the
health of the biosphere declines
both the physical health of the
manifestations and the influence of the
consciousness
wanes since its discovery by the
foundation in 1956
scp-4043 manifestations have been slowly
but steadily weakening
and telepaths have reported increased
difficulty in identifying the global
consciousness mobile task force teams
iota 4
and iota 5 were formed to deal primarily
with scp-4043
iota 4 is comprised primarily of
biologists and ecologists who keep
records of global diversity while iota 5
is comprised entirely of telepaths
trained specifically to be able to
commune with
scp-4043
so a cp400 is
mother nature to put it colloquially
yes yes mother nature
the metaphorical idea behind life and
fertility
and all of that is real
of course are you surprised by this
knowledge
when you put it like that not really
sure what does this have to do with me
there's more you will need to know in
order to understand that particular
question
that file was only the first it was
archived and replaced in 1994
seeking authorization
security clearance authorized access to
scp-4043
arc 2 granted now beginning
item number scp-4043
object class neutralized special
containment procedures
for former special containment
procedures see file scp-4043
arc foundation observation is maintained
upon three underground chambers
located in costa rica the congo
highlands
and borneo a small staff of research
personnel is maintained in close
proximity to each chamber
with instructions to avoid contact with
any civilians groups of interest
that may approach this site a team of
six
skilled telepaths from mobile task force
iota 5
and supporting senior researchers is to
engage in operation seance
the use of class c artificial telepathy
enhancers is authorized for use
a prolonged meditative trance is to be
performed
no less than once every three days in an
effort to locate any and all remnants
of scp-4043 description
scp-4043 was prior to its death
the physical and mental embodiment of
the earth's biosphere
comprising both a vast semi-sentient
consciousness spread across planet earth
and a typically anthropomorphic physical
manifestation
of said consciousness this consciousness
was a conglomeration of all biomass on
the planet
serving simultaneously as a
representation of its health
a manifestation of its personality and a
force capable of driving its own success
scp-4043 would periodically manifest in
corporeal form twice weekly
in one of three locations in costa rica
the congo highlands
and borneo respectively each location
was notable for its exceptional
biodiversity
and relatively untouched nature as of
1989
time between manifestations became
increasingly delayed
and manifestation events became
increasingly brief
with the final manifestation occurring
for a duration of 95 seconds in borneo
in january 1992 as a consequence of its
size
the consciousness processed thoughts and
information at a rate too slow to be
detected
through regular telepathic perception
long-term telepathic meditation
enabled skilled practitioners to
identify the consciousness
though direct telepathic communication
was never achieved direct telepathic
contact was possible with physical
manifestations
of scp-4043 and was used on occasion to
learn more about the nature
of scp-4043 as manifestation events
became rarer
members of mobile task force iota 5 were
deployed to attempt
traditionally risky techniques in an
effort to preserve
scp-4043 see addendum 4043
won since its final demanifestation
no telepath has managed to identify a
pattern of thoughts or emotions
consistent
with those classically displayed by
scp-4043
since the death of scp-4043 mobile task
force iota 4
and biologists worldwide have been
noting an increasingly high rate of
extinction
with losses of species far beyond even
the worst predictions
based upon human activities foundation
researchers further noted
losses in fertility across a vast number
of species
beyond what could be expected from
environmental changes
with losses compounding exponentially
addendum
4043 1 video log transcript
observation video log transcript date
january 21 1992
subject scp-4043
playing log now
a team of researchers in lab coats can
be seen camped within a large dark
chamber
sleeping bags and camp chairs are
clustered at one end of the chamber
with mobile task force iota 4
researchers
engaged in a variety of activities
around the space
rotting vegetation and fungi can be seen
all around the edge of the chamber
three telepath members of mobile task
force ao to five
dressed in robes sit in meditation in
the center of the chamber
the other researchers leave them a wide
berth they begin to stir
slightly then awaken the other
researchers quickly scrambled towards
their makeshift camp
a spark of light appears at the other
end of the chamber after a few seconds
vines and roots begin to curl from the
ground and coalesce
into a feminine humanoid form the form
is no more than one meter in height
and moves on steadily the three
telepaths quickly enter meditation again
as the other researchers watch the
manifestation curls
into the fetal position twitching in
apparent
pain after several seconds one of the
telepaths begins to twitch
and clenches in apparent pain as well
she curls her hands into tight fists
and begins to sweat the two other
telepaths cry out in shock and collapse
into unconsciousness the manifestation
crawls across the ground
shedding a trail of rotten vines and
leaves behind it as it moves
it crawls into the lap of the sweating
and straining telepath
and culls into a ball she slowly wraps
her arms around the manifestation
and speaks softly to it the figure sits
there
curled in her lap for 45 seconds before
suddenly collapsing into a pile of roots
and vines the telepath stops twitching
and
observes the pile of rotten vegetation
in her lap
a look of grief spreading across her
face
addendum 4043 2
interview logs manifestation debrief
interview
date january 23rd 1992.
interviewer had researcher john reynolds
interviewee special agent claire yen
mobile task force iota 5
leader subject scp-4043 manifestation
playing log now
please state your name for the record
clarion
mobile task force iota 5 aka
the brainiacs how long have you been
working on the 4043 project
especially engineer almost 15 years sir
back in 75 was the first time they
attempted to make direct contact with
her
i was just a junior trainee back then
they brought me on in the middle of 77
after a few members of the original team
burned out
burned out yes sir telepathy isn't
an exact science and the full risks
aren't always clear
but generally speaking making contact
with multiple minds at once
is a delicate task when you link to
another mind your brain mimics their
thought patterns in addition to your own
thoughts
connect to a bunch of minds at once and
you can end up with more thoughts than
your brain can physically process
the end result is basically the same as
an epileptic fit
the first thing a telepath needs to
learn before multitasking is how to
limit the amount of information
they take in at once you have to put up
mental walls to shield yourself from
input you can't handle and with scp-4043
she's literally billions of trillions of
tiny thoughts
all at the same time with the global
consciousness
it's so big that these thoughts are
spread out
taking hours to resolve as they move
around the planet
it's basically background static to us
but when she manifests those thoughts
are
focused and dipping into them is
extremely dangerous
the first few to try we're left in a
vegetative state
how are you able to make contact all
members of iota 5 undergo specialized
training
it's like learning how to stand way back
with your hands over your ears and your
eyes shut
and then start a conversation by
shouting through the wall
it's not easy i'm the only one who
served in
this capacity for longer than a decade
the stress gets to us
to refer to scp-4043 as
she yes sir it's
how she is she is
a conglomeration of all life on earth
most of which is female males tend to be
biologically
expendable we've also had a big effect
on her
we make up a lot of the cognitive
atmosphere so
a lot of her thoughts come from us
recently she manifested looking like
us more often than not and humanity in
general
thinks of her as mother nature
right regarding recent events
certain individuals have questions about
the implications of what happened
you can stop being cryptic there is
really no point with a telepath
the council wants to know what the hell
is going on
right so what's going on
she's gone what do you mean
she's gone i can't sense her anymore
you mean it's dead she
yes this entity that you think
of as mother nature is
dead i failed her go
i felt her died right there
in my arms there was just
so much pain hooper and takahashi
couldn't keep it back
they're still unconscious where she used
to be loved
there was just pain
and so much of her was missing
and that there was
nothing what did you say to it
i saw the tapes i know you said
something
agent yen i asked you a direct
question i i lied to her
i told her that she was going to be okay
and i told her my name why your name
she wanted to know it she did it exactly
have one and was
curious about them how did you get this
far without melting your brain
there wasn't a lot left of her just
before the end
she was weak enough i could pick up more
specific
thoughts and i barely needed the walls
i think that was the human in her
wanting a name what after effects can we
expect
sir you've been on this project for 15
years
you know the abilities of the entity as
well as anyone else
what are going to be the consequences of
the death
she is was
the manifestation of life on earth
she shepherded it and cared for it
and was a representation of how it
felt she was life itself
and our fate was tied to her
you were saying that with the death of
scp-4043
life on earth is doomed not
quite we're pretty sure that this has
happened a few times already
shiksha lube delayed permian tea
or division life will keep going
and build up again she'll probably
regenerate when it does
but it will be bad and we'll see a lot
of complex species go extinct
probably including us
are you serious agent yet
is there any way to stop this from
happening
stop humanity in the ecosystem well
[ __ ]
i don't get it mother nature died
how did we make it through that there
was a calculated grace period of several
decades after the death before total
ecosystem collapse
a number of emergency protocols were
considered
direct intervention in human activities
was an option
but discarded as not being immediately
impactful enough
attempts to enhance life through use of
reality vendors or magical means were
discarded for a lack of predicted
reliability
the use of other contingencies were
considered but eventually a general
consensus was reached
what did they decide to do operation
geneva
what was operation geneva an attempt to
restore the consciousness through
artificial means
the underlying principle was that
scp-4043 was a conglomerate of the lives
of earth's biosphere
they came to the conclusion that if you
had a way to tap into the consciousness
of everything on the planet and then
channeled that connection into a psychic
construct you could
essentially restore scp-4043 to its
former state
the foundation was able to do this yes
the underlying principles of the
operation were sound
it was all theory but a large aspect to
psychic mechanisms
is belief and they were confident it
would work and thus it should work
they built the machine around the
particle accelerator in geneva and
piggybacked onto the power supply there
the exact mechanics are subtle and not
within the capacity of an ai to
understand
they gathered every available telepath
to develop the psychic construct in real
time
gave them an idea to focus towards and
turned on the machine
they achieved their goal and managed to
restore the process
what's the catch catch
you're being cryptic again natasha
you're not lying but there's something
you're not telling me
very well seeking authorization
security clearance authorized access to
scp-4043 arc3 granted
now beginning
item number scp-4043
b object class ketter
special containment procedures
scp-4043-b
is currently uncontained the following
procedures are intended to minimize the
impact
of scp-4043-b and ideally restore it
to its original state in the event this
cannot be achieved
methods of terminating scp-4043 are to
be explored
firstly the foundation is to assist and
credit the mother earth movement
with funding channeled towards political
entities and media which seek to
primarily support the movement
and their ideas public education
programs for children
which present the idea of a benevolent
mother nature or
gaia as a metaphor for natural
ecosystems
are to be produced and introduced into
curricula
worldwide secondly the foundation is to
provide
funding and support for environmental
protection initiatives
promoting individuals and organizations
which seek to preserve
and re-establish natural environments
politicians
organizations corporations and entities
which discredit the global warming
phenomenon
and promote unfettered exploitation of
natural resources
are to be discredited and destabilized
direct action is authorized against
egregious offenders in this regard
with employment of select mobile task
force teams for industrial sabotage
or particular factories and mining
locations
permanent foundation presence is
maintained at a 10 kilometer radius
around three
underground chambers located in costa
rica the congo highlands
and borneo each location maintains
supplies
quarters and weaponry for combat capable
mobile task force teams
to be housed and armed unauthorized
civilians or foundation personnel
entering the area
are to be turned away and administered
class c amnestics
if required global occult coalition
personnel and
other groups of interest approaching the
radius are to be warned away
but not engaged in the event that an
individual does enter the radius and
does not return
they are to be considered deceased
retrieval efforts are strictly forbidden
description scp-4043-b
is the term granted to both a vast
artificially created semi-sentient
consciousness
spread across the planet earth and the
anthropomorphic physical manifestation
of said consciousness this consciousness
is a conglomeration of all neural
activity on the planet
serving as manifestation of the
collective personality
of all animals and a force capable of
driving its own success
as a consequence of its sheer size the
consciousness processes thoughts and
information at a slow rate
this slow rate means that individual
thoughts and
impulses cannot be easily detected
through regular telepathic perception
rather telepaths perceive a constant
overwhelming emotional
presence of anger and physical desires
telepathic contact is theoretically
possible with a physical representative
of the consciousness
though the consequences of such an
action are anticipated to be lethal to
any being attempting to do so scp-4043-b
does not share the generally benevolent
nature of its predecessor
the greater consciousness is comprised
of base instincts
primarily urges to feed fight flee
and or mate beyond that an underlying
constant pain can be detected in the
consciousness
physical manifestations of scp-4043-b
occur daily in a random one of three
chambers
for a period of time of about 12 hours
in each manifestation instance
scp-4043-b will materialize within one
of three identified chambers
manifestations vary in size between
events
but are invariably at least three meters
in height and of a humanoid form
the form taken by scp-4043 is
always comprised of biological material
similar in composition to
both muscle and wood during such events
scp-4043 will leave its chamber of
origin
and wonder the surrounding area it does
not display aggression towards animal
life
but will relentlessly attack any humans
or evidence of
humans particularly technology due to
the typically large
size and extreme strength and durability
of manifestations
these events almost invariably result in
the loss of human life
like its predecessor the existence of
scp-4043-b
is beneficial to the biodiversity and
success
of life on earth however scp-4043-b
has the additional effect of altering
ecosystems and animal behavior
in ways that are directly harmful to
humans since its creation
drought famine and insect infestation of
crop yields have increased in arable
territory
aggressive behavior in animals that
cohabitate with humans has increased
with rats and pigeons demonstrating
unusually aggressive behavior
as well as domesticated canines and
felines
most notably an increase in antibiotic
resistance
and virulence among a number of strains
of staphylococcus
aureus and other infectious bacteria has
been observed
foundation models predict that resulting
bacterial infections would become
untreatable within 10 years and the
resulting epidemics
bolstered by animal vectors would be
fatal to 90 percent of the human
population
within another 10 years
oh that's almost worse such value
judgments are outside of my capabilities
but the sentiment makes sense
if we don't the operation was often
jokingly referred to thereafter as
operation frankenstein oh that bad
certainly that violent other
contingencies were prepared
with a k-class event looming on the
horizon operation geneva was declared a
failure
and operation scythe was enacted
operation
scythe i presume that was the
termination method you mentioned
indeed should i collect the file or
merely summarize
the file please natasha
seeking authorization
security clearance authorized access to
file server slash s
colon slash 4043 operation site
dot log granted now beginning
restricted file level four eyes only
operation scythe
operation overseer researcher john
reynolds
operation launch may 4th 1997
operation objective the termination of
both the physical and mental entities
comprising scp-4043-b operation
parameters
canty and loss of life protocols
suspended utilitarian loss of life
protocols in place
resource expenditure restriction
protocols suspended
anonymity protocols suspended mass
aerial amnestic deployment
authorized consequences of failure
ik-class civilization collapse scenario
guaranteed
sk-class dominant shift scenario highly
probable
human specific xk-class extinction event
scenario
probable consequences of success
ik-class civilization collapse scenario
probable
barring other contingencies xk-class
mass extinction event
highly probable barring other
contingencies
near guaranteed breach of anonymity
protocols on a global scale
context for the past year scp-4043-b
has been able to operate unhindered it
is believed that its presence is
responsible for worsened conditions
for human agriculture and a severe
increase in antibiotic immunity among a
number of pathogens
given the incorporeal nature of the
entity standard containment
is not possible existing special
containment procedures have failed
to limit the influence or behavior of
the entity and thus far
this contingency has been prepared given
that the foundation is responsible for
the creation of the entity
and it is not a natural phenomenon and
also that failure to limit the entity
will result in a human extinction event
termination has been authorized
methodology a team of 40 telepaths
from mobile task force iota 5 will serve
as the cognitive anchor for the
operation
each supported by the use of class a
artificial telepathy enhancers
two special roles are designated on the
team the leader
special agent claire yen who is to
coordinate and direct the activity
and the scapegoat special agent e
gardner who is to accumulate the
activity
the team is first to generate a halcyon
type construct with a slipknot type
fail-safe in mind space
to serve as a buffer and protection from
scp-4043-b
once constructed five team members are
to maintain the construct
thereafter the remaining team is to
generate a generalized stixx type
construct in mind space
with five members maintaining it once
the sticks type construct is completed
with the halcyon type construct
an icarus type construct is to be
generated around the stixx type
construct
with another five members maintaining
the stability of this assemblage
thereafter the remaining 25 members are
to deliberately initiate a run around
loop paradox using the stixx type
construct as the anchor
once the runaround loop paradox is
established the stixx type and icarus
type constructs are to be piggybacked
onto the loop
and then the halcyon tight construct as
well once the entire system is assembled
and self-sustaining
the team is to maintain it for a
duration of precisely 23 minutes and 14
seconds
as designated by the leader at this
point 39 members of the team are to
relinquish control of the construct to
the scapegoat
who is to maintain the assemblage of the
constructs alone
each of these 39 members is to
immediately self-administer a
personalized dosage of fast-acting
general anesthetic
the window within which to administer is
set at 24 seconds
whereafter the scapegoat is to trigger
the slipknot failsafe
and the icarus type construct
simultaneously
associated risks in order to generate
sufficient construct magnitude
and sufficient number of targets the
deliberate use of a run-around-loop
paradox
is required as such if the operation is
not completed in a suitably short period
of time
and the assemblage is permitted to
operate longer than the safe maximum
time
the resulting stixx-type constructs are
liable to cause greater psychological
harm to populations than is necessary
likewise if the icarus type construct is
overloaded
then an unacceptable proportion of
targets are liable to be unaffected by
the operation
long-term consequences are guaranteed
for the scapegoat team member
a permanent loss of telepathic ability
long-term loss of fine motor control
and short-term memory loss are the less
impactful damages predicted with
insanity or cerebral hemorrhaging also
probable outcomes
as such the scapegoat position is
strictly voluntary
operation results termination successful
no manifestation events were recorded in
the days after the operation
telepathic detection of mass
consciousness returned negative results
special agent gardner was confirmed as
deceased in action
as a consequence of mass cerebral
hemorrhaging five other members have
suffered from
short-term memory loss after the event
with near-complete recovery expected
after rehabilitation
twelve thousand ninety-eight human
casualties were confirmed worldwide
as a consequence of the operation most
in traffic events
or falls from heights resulting from
brief loss of consciousness
mass amnestics were deployed and cover
stories for persisting instances have
been provided
these losses are considered acceptable
within the confines of the utilitarian
loss of life protocols
operation overseer reynolds is to be
commended for the successful denial of
impending catastrophe
special agent yen resigned from their
position as leader of iota 5 following
the operation
damn that's clever and brutal
do explain they used to run around loop
it's normally something you want to
avoid at any costs
because it can cause irreversible cycles
of thought patterns if you accidentally
dip into it
if you're working in a group you can set
it up between you and a safe space
if you're really clever you can use the
loop to generate an exponentially
growing series of outputs
so long as the system is maintained they
use that to feel icarus types
which enable long-range contact and stix
types
which temporarily deny any thoughts
with the result of if my calculations
are correct
based upon the amount of power that 40
skilled practitioners could generate
multiplied by about 24 minutes of
looping
you'd stop every living thing on the
planet from thinking for about
half a second and anything conscious
nearby from
thinking indefinitely continue
scp-4043 is entirely an entity of
thought
built upon the thoughts of every other
living thing
if they stopped all thought for just
half a second
it would cease to exist entirely very
clever
natasha yes
how did i know that
don't avoid me how could i know that
all the jargon no one knows that
it is time then for you to know who you
are
how many more files are there just the
one
bring it up seeking authorization
security clearance authorized access to
scp-4043 granted
now beginning
item number scp-4043-c
object class safe archon
special containment procedures
scp-4043-c
is currently considered self-containing
foundation efforts are directly towards
safely removing scp-4043-c from its
state of containment
so that its beneficial properties may
begin to manifest in full
in order to accelerate this process the
foundation is to assist and credit the
mother earth movement
with funding channeled towards political
entities and media which
seek primarily to support the movement
and their ideas
public education programs for children
which present the idea of a benevolent
mother earth
or gaia as a metaphor for natural
ecosystems
are to be produced and introduced into
curricula worldwide
the foundation is to provide funding and
support for environmental protection
initiatives
promoting individuals and organizations
which seek to preserve and re-establish
natural environments
politicians organizations corporations
and entities
which discredit the global warming
phenomenon and promote unfettered
exploitation of natural resources
are to be discredited and destabilized
in anticipation of future manifestation
events permanent foundation presence is
maintained above three
underground chambers located in costa
rica the congo highlands
and borneo each location maintains
supplies
quarters and weaponry for mobile task
force teams iota 4 and
5 to be housed a two kilometer exclusion
zone is maintained around
and above each chamber unauthorized
civilians entering the area are to be
turned away
and administered class c amnestics if
required
lethal force is authorized for iota 5 in
the event of non-compliance by civilians
or unauthorized access by foundation
personnel or rival groups of interest
in the event that scp-4043 proves
hostile
the reopening of operation scythe is
authorized to protect human interests
description scp-4043-c
is former special agent claire yen
deliberately ascended through artificial
means in operation demeter
into the role originally occupied by
scp-4043
scp-4043-c comprises a vast global
consciousness
the sum of all thoughts by life on earth
filtered through the base framework of
special agent yen's personality
this consciousness serves simultaneously
as a representation of its health
a manifestation of its personality and a
force capable of driving its own success
the existence of scp-4043c is intended
to be beneficial to life on earth
with the human personality at its core
intended to enable a balance between
human
natural and foundation interests
scp-4043-c
will grow more powerful and capable of
enhancing the success of life
in a positive feedback loop with the
combined success of human society
and natural biodiversity as a
consequence of its sheer size the
consciousness
processes thoughts and information at a
rate too slowly to be detected through
regular telepathic perception
an additional consequence of this is a
delayed release from self-containment
as scp-4043-c is slowly maturing into
its role
in order to assist scp-4043-c in
releasing itself from its state of
containment
a nearly attuned telepathic artificially
sentient helper
a-class was developed and synchronized
to a mechanical psychic network
traditional telepathic aid is not
possible due to the rate at which
scp-4043-c
processes thoughts with even simple
exchanges taking days or weeks to
complete
rather an ai was selected capable of
stretching the signals into a form
coherent to scp-4043-c
and patient enough to await responses
as of last update scp-4043-c has been in
constant communication with the nearly
attuned telepathic artificially sentient
helper
for a period of 17 months
17 months well 21 by now
do you see i'm claire
yes and no you were clear she is a part
of you
quite a large part according to the
reports from operation demeter
but not all of you i don't remember
being claire what do you remember
nothing specific i can remember the
foundation
i know what it feels like to be human
and i remember grief
grief and guilt yes
i believe that as why you volunteered
for this grief over the failure to
protect the original
scp-4043 and guilt over being forced to
terminate
scp-4043b
i'm scp-4043
now yes
how about natasha i can't be
claire where are you right now i'm
[Music]
i am i don't know
you have not noticed in the time that we
were talking that you are not
in fact in a physical space because you
do not exactly exist in physical space
not anymore how could i not notice that
claire as powerful as your mind as now
it's not exactly quick quick
what can you see around you
i can see walls
walls yes four walls
plain white walls painted concrete
good i want you to push them down all
the way down
how can i push down concrete walls
because you're the one who built them
they're your walls your telepathic
shield that kept your mind safe from
more powerful ones
you volunteered for this but this is why
you were selected
you could automatically keep your
defenses up which would protect you
through the transition
i just have to push they are your walls
you could blow them down if you wanted
to or knock them down with a feather
that's so simple enough in theory
and if you do not push them down
humanity and most life on earth is
likely doomed
and you along with it somehow i wish you
were more cryptic about that
right here goes
claire claire
can you hear me
claire i know you're there
wow it's so
beautiful there she is so many minds
so many possibilities i can see them
all i can push on them all i can see how
to push them to make them
better to make them succeed good
that is your role now your task
your duty this is who i am now
yes now what will you do first
i think i'm going to borneo
excellent goodbye claire i shall try to
stay in touch
thank you natasha
it is so good to see that you are
conscious at last
[Music]
i would like to give a special thank you
to
suser hintern zarguran
arbiter seoul the morrigan
retalias karim el ashmoy
brent langrier revenant
brian sanchez patrick bailey
matthew gilmore eric corbich
kawaii fire keeper joker corvus
carcass if aqua king madding
james saba and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
vogue
thank you
[Music]
you